وينضم إليّ الآن لمناقشة
السياق الأوسع للصراع،
ويقول كاتب العمود في صحيفة نيويورك تايمز توم فريدمان
إنه كان رئيس صحيفة التايمز في كل من بيوت
والقدس وهو مؤلف
كتاب اسم التطبيق من بيروت إلى القدس
وقد فاز بأول كتابين له  تقارير الجوائز
من المنطقة، من الجيد وجودك
معنا توم، دعني أسألك أولاً، هل
تفكر في هذا أه كثيرًا، أنت
دائمًا مهتم بالتكنولوجيا وما
يلفت انتباهك بشأن عدم التماثل في
هذا الهجوم على حماس بعد كل شيء  إن
الإرهاب الضعيف مقارنة بجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي هو دائمًا
سلاح الضعفاء، ومع ذلك فقد
تمكنوا من تحقيق شيء غير
عادي تمامًا، ويرجع ذلك جزئيًا إلى
المفاجأة والوحشية التي
عرفتها، وأعتقد أن هذه الحرب
ستتم دراستها من قبل أجهزة المخابرات في
جميع أنحاء العالم.  أعلم، اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ
بالقول إن الكثير من الناس يقولون إن
هذا هو 911 الإسرائيلي، وهذا أمر سخيف.
911 كان حدثًا غير متخيل تمامًا حيث
سيحول الناس طائرات ركاب إلى
تفجيرات انتحارية، كان هذا متوقعًا تمامًا، وكان
هذا متوقعًا تمامًا، وقد
قامت إسرائيل ببناء جدار مليار دمية من أجل  منع
هذا فحقيقة أن هذا الجدار تم
اختراقه بواسطة جرافة
أم أه بواسطة أه فلسطيني وأه حماس
في أه تعرف سيارات صغيرة
تقود سياراتها الخاصة كيف
حدث ذلك أولاً كيف حافظوا على
المفاجأة كان هذا أمرًا معقدًا للغاية
هجوم متطور يتضمن
طائرات بحرية برية وجوية بدون طيار تم التخطيط له على مدى
فترة طويلة من الزمن، ألم يستخدموا
الهواتف المحمولة كانت تلك الهواتف المحمولة
ملثمة بطريقة ما أه ربما بمساعدة
إيران ليس لدي أي فكرة لذلك نحن بحاجة إلى
فهم كيف هذا  أم في الأساس، كما
تعلمون أه قوة صغيرة جدًا مسلحة بما
يكفي من التكنولوجيا أه تمكنت من
مفاجأة وقهر ما
يعتبر واحدًا من أكثر
الجيوش ذكاءً من الناحية التكنولوجية في
العالم، لقد كنت تكتب منذ
فترة عن هذه الحكومة الإسرائيلية اليمينية الجديدة
وتصرفاتها  في الضفة الغربية،
لديها أعضاء يتحدثون عن
ضم كل الضفة الغربية في غزة، هل
تعتقد أن هذا لعب دورًا في
نوع من الخلفية لهذا
الهجوم الذي تم تحريره، سيكون هناك يومًا ما، أنا
متأكد من نوع ما  اه لجنة تحقيق
في هذه الحرب اه اه وإذا كان علي أن أكتب أه لائحة
الاتهام رقم واحد فسوف تذهب إلى
وزير العدل الإسرائيلي ياريف لافين
تذكر هذا الاسم يارييف في ني
هو الرجل الذي قاد هذا
الجهد المجنون الفاسد وغير النزيه من أجل أه
الاستيلاء على السلطة  من المحكمة العليا
تحت اسم المراجعة القضائية،
وعندما فعل ذلك بمساعدة نتنياهو،
مزق إسرائيل، مزق المجتمع الإسرائيلي، مزق
جيش الوزارة الإسرائيلية، فجر،
مزق سلاح الجو الإسرائيلي،
فجر ما يقرب من 40 أسبوعًا من خروج 100 ألف
إسرائيلي كل يوم سبت  ليلة
أه احتجاجًا على هذا أه الأسبوع الماضي،
نقلت في الواقع عن
مسؤول سابق في وزارة الدفاع الإسرائيلية قوله إن
استعداداتنا تضررت بسبب هذا
الكسر الكامل لمجتمعنا، ومن
هنا بدأ هذا وإذا تمكنت من كتابة
لائحة الاتهام، فسيكون هو
رقم الشخص المتهم  واحد لكن نتنياهو مكنه
وقال لي يجب أن أطلعك على
القضايا الأوسع أه ماذا يعني هذا
بالنسبة لصفقة التطبيع السعودية
يبدو أن الأمر أصبح أكثر
تعقيدا لأنك الآن
أشعلت المشاعر في الشارع العربي كما
يقولون  أم هل تعتقد أن
السعوديين لا يهتمون بذلك
وينظرون إلى الأمر عمليا وهناك من
مصلحتهم أعتقد تحرر على المدى الطويل
أه مصالحهم في التطبيع
مع إسرائيل وستنتصر تلك المصالح
على المدى الطويل ولكن على المدى القصير،
هذه الحرب بين إسرائيل وإسرائيل تجعل
ذلك مستحيلاً أعتقد أنه إذا لم تقم إيران
أه بتحفيزها أو تشجيعها فمن المؤكد أنها
تفهم أنها مستفيد كبير من ذلك، وكان
آخر شيء فازت به إيران هو
التحالف الاستراتيجي الأمريكي السعودي الإسرائيلي
لموازنة إيران، لذا في الوقت الحالي
لم يعد هذا أه لم يعد
ممكنًا